[Música]
su discurso del estado de la nación en
él el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin se
concentró enteramente en el desarrollo
de la guerra en Ucrania una operación
militar que estaba planeada para durar
pocas semanas pero que este viernes
completa un año entre combates sus
palabras cargadas de nacionalismo y
rechazo a occidente incluyeron también
acusaciones como que la otan ha impedido
una solución dialogada también Putin
anunció la suspensión de su país en el
tratado New stark que protege al mundo
de una mayor proliferación nuclear horas
después el presidente estadounidense Joe
biden habló desde Polonia y reafirmó el
respaldo de occidente y de la otan a
Polonia para que Rusia no pueda ganar la
guerra según él si esto ocurre el
expansionismo saldría victorioso para
hablar del tema nos acompaña layos sasdy
analista de relaciones internacionales y
estudios estratégicos de fuerzas
militares rusas además es profesora
adjunto de la Universidad Interamericana
de Puerto Rico profesor sasy Gracias por
acompañarnos las reacciones más
preocupantes al discurso de Putin tienen
que ver con el New Start porque es la
otan dijo que nadie estaba atacando a
Rusia y le pidió que reconsiderara su
posición Estados Unidos también condenó
la noticia porque cree que Putin tomó
esta decisión que ya había sido
advertida por Washington y usted la
considera como una suerte de amenaza
oxidante
Sí bueno es una situación vamos a ver
dijo Putin que suspende el tratado pero
que no se retira del tratado en los
límites del tratado nuevo Start es que
tanto Estados Unidos como Rusia tengan
un un tope un techo de
1550 ojivas nucleares por parte para que
tengan una idea el tratado estárte
original o tratado estar tú no eh de los
años 90 ponía un límite máximo de seis
mil ojivas porque realmente
en los años 80
Rusia llegó a tener Diez mil ojivas
nucleares Estados Unidos como once mil
ojivas nucleares Entonces el tratado
Start anterior el primero reducía a un
máximo de seis mil el nuevo tratado
Start que se aprueba y se firma en 2010
este en cuestión que dice Putin que lo
va a suspender limita a 1550 entonces
según cifras del departamento de estado
de Estados Unidos de del septiembre del
año pasado
Rusia habría tenido desplegadas mil
quinientas cuarenta y nueve ojivas
nucleares o sea 1550 el límite del
tratado desplegadas
1549 en septiembre al año pasado tendría
habría tenido Rusia Estados Unidos
1420 ojivas desplegadas O sea que podría
aumentar el número de las desplegadas de
Estados Unidos a 1550 entonces otra cosa
son los vehículos misiles por ejemplo
balísticos cruceros para lanzar esas
ojivas desplegadas el límite máximo de
lanzadores o medios de ataque
estratégicos sería 700 por parte según
el nuevo tratado Star Entonces los rusos
creo que tenían el año pasado en 659
medios no no como cuatrocientos y pico
medios desplegados quinientos y pico 540
Estados Unidos tenía 659 Estados Unidos
cerca del límite de 700 O sea que si
Rusia se mantiene en esos límites Pues
dentro del tratado
O sea pues no sería una mala cosa porque
sería dentro de esos límites si llegara
a violar esos límites Yo diría que ya no
es suspensión del tratado es retirarse
el tratado Ellos dicen que suspenden
pues Supuestamente bajo ese término
Simplemente no aumentarían ni reducirían
el número de ojivas porque ya de por sí
para el año pasado están dentro de los
límites del tratado nuevo Start los
rusos el peligro es
que el número de total de ojivas
nucleares porque ahí hablamos de
estratégicas Pero qué tal de las
tácticas y Según creo que las Federación
de científicos Americanos el año pasado
Rusia habría tenido
cinco mil novecientas setenta y siete
ojivas nucleares en total estratégicas y
tácticas y aquí hay que decir una cosa
eso Por cierto se acerca al límite de
seis mil máximo del tratado startup
original de los años 90 lo voy a
interrumpir precisamente para hacerle
una pregunta y le pido que lo responda
de manera breve porque suspender y no
retirarse de una vez del tratado New
Start
bueno probablemente porque eso
implicaría una es como una forma de
amenazar occidente por su apoyo a
Ucrania es todo y aparentar como que es
duro sí que Rusia tome esa iniciativa de
suspensión pero claro no se retiran
Porque si se retiraran como se retiraron
ambas partes del tratado de armas
nucleares para para eliminar armas
nucleares de alcance intermedio que
Trump se salió el tratado de 1987
eh 1987 creo que era así pues entonces
podría haber una carrera armamentos en
el sector en esta carrera de armamentos
contrasta con los discursos que dieron
los presidentes Vladimir Putin y Joe
biden porque en sus palabras no se
reflejó una posible salida negociada a
la guerra en Ucrania usted que cree que
habla del futuro de la guerra estos
discursos muy brevemente
bueno la guerra sigue porque Putin lo
dijo la guerra en Ucrania ellos van a
seguir Allí están para una guerra larga
es él no va a soltar la presa incluso ya
hay un documento filtrado se dice del
kremlin que para el 2030 querría
entregarse a belarrusa Bielorrusia O sea
que las ambiciones territoriales de
Putin no se limitan incluso a Ucrania
Estados Unidos ha dicho que va a apoyar
a Ucrania sin ambaje lo mismo la Unión
Europea la guerra convencional de
Ucrania es larga el problema son las
armas nucleares que no son estratégicas
y que pueden serlo rapidito un arma
nuclear estratégica puede tener
quinientos kilotones o quinientas mil
toneladas de TNT equivalentes Pero hay
misiles de submarinos lanzados misiles
cruceros que pueden tener unos IVA de
quinientos kilotones y pasan por
tácticos O sea que ahí está el problema
Hay nuevas armas que los rusos tienen
como las armas hipersónicas que pueden
estar armadas con ojivas nucleares
estratégicas pero pasar por tácticas
Solo que la potencia explosiva es como
la de una estratégica claro y claramente
Ahí está claramente ahí está ese
incluidas durante ahí está ese ese ese
añadido importante diferenciar entre
armas estratégicas y tácticas profesor
relayosas y gracias por acompañarnos
gracias a ustedes Adiós Y ustedes sigan
con nosotros Porque en segundos volvemos
con más en directo América
[Música]